F: Tiffany, on a un petit contre plongée dans ton décolleté, je préfère te le dire.
T: Pourquoi?
F: Hein? Ah ben c'est très joli à l'image, c'est pas le problème.
*Rires*
F: Salut, aujourd'hui, je suis où?
Je suis au parc de Belleville.
F: Vous commencez à avoir l'habitude c'est la... c'est la quoi? C'est la 4ème vidéos qu'on fait ensemble?
T: Ouais
F: Et je vais passer de l'autre côté de la caméra parce qu'avant qu'ils partent,
F: j'ai envie d'essayer quelques choses tous ensembles.
F: J'ai avec moi un jeu de cartes un tout petit peu particulier.
F: Avant de vous faire voir ce qu'il y a, à l'intérieur. Il faut que je prépare une prédiction.
F: Et cette prédiction, je vais la faire devant les internautes, devant vous.
F: Je l'écris ici.
F: Comme ça, dans la vidéo, on verra ce que j'ai écris à l'avance.
F: Je l'arrache
F: Tac, Tac, Tac. Geoffrey, je te confie la prédiction.
F: Si tu peux la mettre dans ta petite pochette s'il te plait.
F: Merci, tu es magnifique, tu es formidable.
F: Ce jeu de carte, c'est un jeu de carte particulier parce que ce sont des cartes truquées.
F: Verrez vous le marquage? *Rires*
T: Oui, on voit
F: Voilà, alors ils rient parce que oui, forcément, on voit le marquage
F: Elles sont marquées, mais mélangées quand même, elles sont marquées de 1 à ?
G: 52
Ju: 50
F: On a pas révisé, qu'est ce qu'il nous pose des questions.
T: On voit pas *Rires*
F: C'est de 1 à 52 oui, c'est ça !
G: 52
Ju: À 52
F: Il n'y a pas les jokers
F: Je sais forcément quel numéro est...est écrit derrière quel carte.
T: Ah d'accord !
T: Tu les connais par cœur !
F: Je les connais par cœur, exactement !
F: C'est ce qu'on appelle un chapelet et je me suis entraîner à les retenir.
F: Est ce que vous êtes réceptif ?
T: Non
*Rires*
F: Tout le monde a fait peut être sauf Tiffany qu'a fait non.
F: Moi, mec regarde moi bien, jamais, jamais tu m'influences à que dalle.
F: Tu vas noter des choses au fur et à mesure, si je te dis par exemple de noter 2 de carreau, tu mets 2 avec un carreau.
F: 4 de trèfle.
F: Donc t'écris 4 avec un T
F: Et euh...et Jeff, tu vas devoir retrouver le numéro qui est derrière le 4 de trèfle.
F: Mais je vais t'aider à faire ça, je vais t'aider quand même.
F: Imagine une grande horloge.
F: T'as une horloge qui fait : Tic tac tic tac...
F: Et il y a l'aiguille qui bouge. Elle bouge de plus en plus vite, de plus en plus vite...
F: Elle va s'arrêter sur une heure pleine MAINTENANT.
F: Sur quel heure, elle s'est arrêter ?
Jeff: 15h
F: 15h !
F: Ou 16h
*Rires*
F: Bon apparemment, il veut pas changer donc 15h.
F: Je vais te donner la carte où il y a marqué le n°15...
F: Ne regardez pas pour qu'il y ai du suspens !
F: Tu la gardes dans tes mains sans la retourner.
Jeff: Ouais
F: Super formidable.
F: Valet de carreau.
F: Donc si tu peux noter valet de carreau.
F: Et en face du 4 de trèfle, tu marques 15.
F: On va commencer par toi Julie, le valet de carreau.
F: Le valet de carreau, je l'ai pas choisis par hasard.
F: Je l'ai pris, parce que il est à l'opposé en fait, du potentiel 4 de trèfle, c'est à dire c'est un nombre relativement gros.
F: D'après toi Julie, quel numéro est marqué derrière le valet de carreau ?
Ju: Le 46.
F: 46, pourquoi 46 ?
Ju: Je sais pas, ça m'est sorti comme ça.
F: Ça t'es sorti comme ça !
Ju: Ouais
F: Tu peux changer !
Ju: Non
*Rires*
F: S'il te plaît, non ?
F: Non, non, non, 46 ?
Ju: Ouais 46.
F: Ok 46.
F: Pareil, essayez de pas regarder ce qu'il y à en dessous, si jamais vous voyez pour garder du suspens.
Euh...46, elle est ici.
F: Tu te mets comme Jeff, formidable.
F: Et alors, pour terminer, je vais te demander à toi Tiffany, quelque chose d'assez compliqué.
F: Sur toutes les cartes, je vais te demander d'en choisir une.
F: N'importe laquelle, écoute moi, tu peux prendre n'importe quelle cartes.
F: Tu peux même prendre la dame de cœur si tu veux, mais tous le monde prend la dame de cœur, mais tu peux le prendre quand même.
F: Après, à voir si...
*Rires*
F: Y'a les As, tu vois spontanément...
T: Faut pas que je dise un chiffre alors, je dis une carte.
F: Tu, tu voilà, tu vas dire une carte, n'importe quelle carte...
F: par contre tu...tu prends le temps de le faire, il faut que ça soit un vrai choix
F: Ça peux être un choix classique comme un choix atypique.
F: C'est toi que ça regarde, euh prend pas le 4 de trèfle ou le valet de carreau, potentiellement on a peut être bon.
F: Donc choisis n'importe quelle carte !
T: Ok.
T: Euh, le roi de pique.
F: Le roi de pique.
F: Pourquoi le roi de pique ?
T: Je sais pas.
F: T'as voulu faire compliqué et atypique ou pas ? Parce que il y a un mélange des deux.
T: Bah, c'est un peu opposé à la dame de cœur , tu m'as dit de pas prendre la dame de cœur...
F: Ah oui c'est vrai...
F: Ça, ça serait une influence alors si je voulais le roi de pique.
F: Mais peut être que tu voulais le 3 de pique et que tu as mal prononcé.
T: Non, non *Rires*
F: Le roi de pique ?
T: Roi de pique !
F: Roi de pique, roi de pique...Il est juste là, ok tu le prends, tu en fais ce que tu veux pour le moment.
F: Ok, on va faire un récapitulatif de ce qui s'est passé.
F: Au tout départ, j'ai demandé à mon pote Jeff euh...
F: d'imaginer pour le 4 de trèfle.
T: 4
Jeff: 4 de trèfle.
F: D'imaginer pour le 4 de trèfle, quel nombre il y avait derrière, tu m'avais dit 15, est ce que tu peux retourner ton 15 et nous le faire voir ?
F: C'est bon vu ta tête, ouiiii.
F: Derrière le 4 de trèfle, on a bien 15.
F: Regardez, un petit peu son visage agacé là
*Rires*
F: Julie, valet de carreau, tu m'as dit 46, ça t'es venu vraiment spontanément.
T: Ouais
F: Veux-tu retourner le 46.
F: Valet de carreau !
F: Tadadaadaada *Chantonne*, valet de carreau avec le 46.
F: Et tu m'as dit une carte au hasard, celle que tu voulais toi, tu m'as dit le roi de pique
F: Le roi de pique que je t'es mis dans la main et retourne le roi de pique, on a :
F: Le 30 !
F: Le 30 derrière le roi de pique, c'est bien le 30, exactement la carte que je voulais.
T: Ok
F: C'est celle que je voulais moi !
T: D'accord
F: Voilà, parce que comme on est amis, il faut me croire sur parole.
*Rires*
Jeff: Non, non, non, non, moi je veux plutôt voir le petit bout de papier !
F: Bien joué Jeff, depuis le départ y'a un bout de papier qu'est caché juste ici, juste ici !
F: Y'a une petite prédiction que j'avais fait au départ, pour Jeff mais surtout pour Tiffany.
F: Je vous fais voir ce qu'il y a marqué dans le petit bout de papier depuis le départ...qui se déchire.
Ju: Tu l'arraches.
F: Dans le papier, il y avait simplement marqué 30, mais eux ils le savaient comme je l'avais écrit avant vous.
F: 30
Ju: Super !
Jeff: Bravo !
T: Bravo !
F: *Chantonnes*
T: Bravo, bravo ! *Applaudissements*
F: Ils sont tous influençables *2 *En chantant*
Jeff: T'es un escroc ! *Rires*
T: Ah oui alors moi j'avais oublié !
Ju: Moi aussi j'avais oublié le papier !
G: J'ai rien compris là !
F: Je te donne ça, bah j'espère bien ! *Rires*
Ju: Mais comment...
G: Mais comment pour elle ?
F: Hein ?
Ju: Comment tu pouvais être sûre que...
F: Je t'es hypnotisé, la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu !
F: Merci beaucoup les amis, j'espère que ça vous a plu, que ça vous a fait marrer de voir que vous étiez potentiellement manipulables.
F: Si cette vidéo vous a plu, vous pouvez mettre un petit pouce en l'air !
F: N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne et vous pouvez aussi lâcher un petit commentaire
F: On peut parler de ce qui vient de se passer, ça fera plaisir.
F: Et rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !